j'ai un secret à vos partages j'ai
découvert la caverne d'ali baba
si si je vous assure j'ai même apporté
un échantillon pour vous épater
alors qu'est ce que vous en dites
comment ça ce n'est que de l'eau l'eau
c'est magique c'est magique parce que ça
donne le sourire aux enfants
j'ai grandi dans un conte de montagne
pas si perdu que ça c'était dans les
années 90 la première décennie avant la
grande canicule
à l'époque les étés se suivaient et se
ressemblaient la température montait
tout doucement au cours de la journée
jusqu'à atteindre les 32 degrés celsius
puis sous les coups de 17 18 heures une
odeur très caractéristique commencé à
attiser les narines
à ce moment là invariablement
j'entendais ma mère me dire dépêche-toi
le dit l'orage dans l'air
la tante pouvait durer quelques minutes
ou quelques heures
et quand les précipitations temps
espérer arriver enfin je peux vous
assurer que j'étais plein de jour
aujourd'hui encore j'attends la pluie
avec impatiente parfois plusieurs
semaines durant et c'est bien la force
de courir après les canards du lac
d'observer les avirons et de jouer dans
les ruisseaux ou d'écouter l'appui que
je suis devenue experte en eau enfin
presque
les êtres humains ont très vite intégré
l'importance de la maîtrise de l'énergie
et de l'eau et de l'irrigation aux
canons à neige ou encore des moulins à
aubes aux usines marémotrices en
utilisant ce bien commun dans nos
activités quotidiennes depuis toujours
nous l'avons progressivement polluée et
si je vous disais plus tôt que la
pollution l'eau n'existe pas bon
reprenons depuis le début
l'eau est une molécule composée de deux
atomes de dry d'hydrogène et d'un atome
d'oxygène dans certaines conditions de
pression et de température plusieurs de
ses molécules d'entre elles forme d'un
fluide
par souci de simplification on dénomme
également ce liquide eau et concrètement
alors
concrètement ce récipient contient mille
fois plus de molécules d'eau que le
nombre de fois où il aurait fallu le
remplir pour vider tous les océans du
globe
par contre un liquide qui ne contient
que des molécules d'âge deux eaux ce
n'est pas vraiment ce qu'il ya de plus
fréquents c'est ce qu'on qualifie d' eau
ultra purs et s'intéresse principalement
les chimistes pour comprendre ce qu'il
se passe pour toutes les autres qualités
d'eau imaginez vous un centre commercial
un dimanche de décembre visualisez bien
toutes ces personnes qui viennent faire
leurs emplettes observé à l'est de
boutique en boutique les bras de plus en
plus chargé maintenant remplacer chacune
d'entre elles par un million de
molécules d'eau chaque achat est alors
comme une entité chimique qui vient être
transportés par le fluide et venir
changer la qualité de l'eau commençons
par caractérisé l'eau des océans la plus
présente sur la place dans un
échantillon de filtrer on trouve bien
évidemment l'hydrogène et l'oxygène qui
forment le fluide
ils sont accompagnés d'une soixantaine
d'autres éléments dont ceux qui se
cristallisent en sel de table ce sont
les plus présents avec un ratio
d'environ 1% ce qui revient à dire que
dans cette salle si chacun d'entre vous
est une molécule d'âge au zoo alors je
suis la molécule de la nacelle et cette
eau saumâtre
il faut la diluer 35 fois avec l'ultra
pur des chimistes pourra obtenir l'eau
des rivières et des lacs
pour autant ça n'aurait aucun sens de
dire que l'eau des systèmes du ce à quoi
tic et plus ou moins propre que celle
des océans
ce sont deux qualités différentes
permettant l'épanouissement
d'écosystèmes différents prenons un
autre exemple quand elle était petite ma
mère avait fait l'acquisition d'un
poisson rouge lors d'une kermesse
bubu ma grand mère en bonne ménagère
désinfecter le bocal à la javel pour le
nettoyer le poisson se décollerait peu à
peu parce que d'errer
du dash shaw elle se retrouvait dans son
écosystème mais c'est bizarre quand vous
allez à la piscine vous ne vous
décolorés pas et c'est pas parce que
l'eau contient un peu de chlore qu'elle
est dangereuse c'est tout simplement
parce que les poissons rouges n'ont pas
besoin de la même qualité d'eau pour
vivre que celle que nous utilisons pour
pratiquer un sport
tout ça pour dire qu'il n'y a ni eau
propre ni aux salles seulement des
qualités de différentes destinées à des
usages différents
ok alors l'inexistence de l'eau sale
implique-t-elle forcément l'absence de
pollution dans les eaux caractérise ce
qui est la pollution la pollution c'est
la présence d'une ou de plusieurs
nouvelles entités dans un écosystème et
qu'elles soient physiques chimiques ou
biologiques elles doivent être dans des
proportions suffisantes pour que le
système ne puisse pas s'adapter
par ailleurs le principe chimiques de
lavoisier énoncé en 1789 indique que
rien ne se perd rien ne se crée tout se
transforme
vu sous ces deux ans notre société et à
musique
elle a oublié qu'elle a transformé puis
déplacée elle s'évertue donc à triturer
la croûte terrestre pour aller chercher
des matières premières et paradoxalement
s'étonne de leur épuisement
alors que les cartes ou plutôt les
ressources ont été redistribuées alors
je vous la corde
c'est pas évident trouver une mine
exploitables c'est un petit peu comme
aller chercher charlie sur une grande
affiche de cinéma alors qu'il faudrait
plutôt repéré le petit parchemin pour
espérer trouver des gisements de
ressources secondaire mais finalement
cette redistribution permet d'avoir les
ressources au plus près des besoins
je dois vous l'avouer je côtoie beaucoup
l'eau des égouts
c'est un mélange d'urines de matières
fécales et doit utiliser pour des
nettoyages de toutes sortes et au risque
de vous décevoir ce n'est ce réseau
souterrain ne sert pas abriter
les tortues mutantes non c'est une
autoroute vers des piscines réservées
aux bactéries elles font un énorme
travail de séparation et de
transformation et pour les motiver un
peu on leur apporte parfois de l'oxygène
en mode jacuzzi on obtient ainsi une eau
assainies comme celle que je vous ai
amené sa qualité est correcte pour aller
à la rivière et ce qui faisait son
incompatibilité avec le milieu naturel
se retrouve principalement dans les bons
celles ci sont majoritairement composés
d'azoté de phosphore et de matières
organiques
ce sont les engrais nécessaires à
l'agriculture qui va nous permettre de
générer de la nourriture qui finira
inévitablement à la station d'épuration
alors de l'eau des engrais de l'énergie
c'est bien c'est ce qu'on fait
actuellement de mieux dans les stations
d'épuration mais il manque un petit
quelque chose pour obtenir le précieux
sésame
les métaux ces métaux qu'on est allé
chercher dans la croûte terrestre qu'on
a déplacé et transformer une part
non-négligeable arrive jusqu'à la
station d'épuration jusqu'à maintenant
il était considéré dans l'assainissement
comme neutre et la plupart d'entre eux
retourner au milieu naturel tel quel en
s'intéressant à leur récupération dans
la station d'épuration on a
l'opportunité d'éviter un problème
environnemental tout en fournissant des
ressources aux industries ça ne va pas
être évident il y à 63 métaux a attrapé
challenge accepté à amsterdam où le
projet kwr se focalise sur la
récupération du cuivre est aussi à
bruxelles où le projet sublime us a
permis de breveter une nouvelle
technologie encore une fois à base de
bactéries
vous l'avez sûrement deviné je fais le
métier d'ingénieur en récupération
des ressources de l'eau et si j'ai pu
vous parler de toutes ces qualités
d'aujourd'hui c'est parce que j'ai suivi
le premier dogmes et des ingénieurs
observé alors je vous rassure pas besoin
d'être scientifique pour le mettre en
pratique
je vous invite donc à venir avec moi
explorez nomine qu'ils sont constitués
par les toilettes et les égouts et
surtout à découvrir de nouvelles caverne
d'ali baba pour qu'enfin la pollution de
l'eau n'existe plus